let's get some practice subtracting
mixed numbers so let's say that I had
two and 5/8 minus minus one and two
eight minus one and two eighths what is
this going to be and I encourage you to
pause the video and try to work it out
well we could rewrite this we could
write the numbers on top of each other
we could say this is to do that magenta
color say this is two and five-eighths
actually let me write them a little bit
further spaced apart two and 5/8 minus
minus one and two eighths and then we
can subtract and we could say okay look
in this column right over here we are
subtracting eight we have five eighths
and we're going to subtract two eighths
if I have five of something and I
subtract two of them I'm going to have
three of that something and in this case
we're talking about eighths so five
eighths minus two eighths is going to be
three eighths and then you have two ones
minus one one or two minus one is going
to be one so this is going to be equal
to one and three eighths now let's do
something more interesting let's say
that we had three I'm just going to make
up a number here three and two-fifths
three and two fifths minus minus two and
three fifths and like always pause the
video and try to work it out let's try
to work it out this exact same way so
I'm going to rewrite it as three let me
do that same magenta color trouble
changing colors we have three and two
over five minus -2 and 3 over 5 two and
three over five and when you first try
to do it over here you had five eighths
minus two ways that was easy to figure
out that's three eighths but then over
here you have two fifths minus
three-fifths well that's hard three
fifths is larger than two-fifths so what
can you do here well one option is to
regroup let's take one from I guess you
could say the ones place here so let's
take one from this
and then that's going to turn into two
and then one is the same thing as 5/5 so
2 plus 5/5 is equal to seven fifths so
another way of thinking about it I'll do
it over here we could write we could
write the same 3 and 2/5 is the same
thing as two and seven fifths two and
seven fifths these two things are
equivalent why
well I took one away from here to get to
two and then I added that one over here
one is the same thing as five fifths two
fifths plus five is seven fifths so now
if we consider this if we consider this
thing to be two and seven fifths we're
ready to subtract if you say seven
fifths if you say seven fifths minus
three-fifths that's going to be four
fifths and then you have two minus two
is zero one so you're just going to be
left with four fifths so this is just
going to be four fifths let's do that
again let's do one where we have to
regroup again and I'll just write it out
in a column up down to begin with let's
say that we have seven and seven and one
six minus minus four and four and five
six minus four and five six so what is
this going to be equal to well when we
try to subtract five six from one six
well that's hard five six is larger than
one six but we can regroup we could take
one from here so the seven becomes a six
and then we take that one which is the
same thing as six sixths and add it to
one six so 1/6 + 6 6 is going to be 7 6
is going to be 7 6 let me be clear what
I did I took one from the 7 and it
became 6 and 1 is equal to 1 is equal to
6 6 and so I added 6 6 to that one 6 and
I got 7 6 so I took the 1 from here and
I added it over here and the whole
purpose is now 7 6 is greater than 5 6
so 7 6 - 5 6 is I'm doing that
orange color is 2 6 and 6-4 6-4 is 2 so
it's going to be 2 + 2 6 or if we wanted
to rewrite 2 6
let's see they're both divisible by 2
this is the same thing as 2 and 1/3 is
equivalent to 2 6 so you could also
write it like that